الأخبار العاجلة على تلفزيون الكرملين الذي يسيطر على الكرملين
تزعم أن قوات موسكو تواجه
هجمات ضخمة في جنوب أوكرانيا ،
هاجمت القوات الأوكرانية
بدبابات الناتو والمركبات المدرعة الخفيفة ، وقد
تصدى جيشنا لهذه الهجمات ،
وأصدرت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
مقاطع فيديو جوية مثل هذه التي يُزعم أنها
تُظهر قواتها تستهدف
التشكيلات الأوكرانية المتقدمة  في
منطقة زاباريتا ، تدعي موسكو أيضًا أنها
استولت على نظام رادار غربي حديث مضاد للطائرات
بالقرب من خط
المواجهة في زيارة إلى مستودع أسلحة.
هناك حاجة للإسراع في
الوقت الذي لم يؤكد فيه الأوكرانيون
العمليات الهجومية ولا تستطيع شبكة CNN
التحقق بشكل مستقل من
المزاعم الروسية المحددة التي قال المسؤولون الأمريكيون لشبكة
CNN إن الروس يطرحون
قيادة مقاومة شديدة يقولون إنهم يدركون أن
هجومهم المضاد سيكون طويلًا وصعبًا
وهم  ستحتاج إلى الكثير من الدروع
لاختراق دفاعات روسيا ، فقد
أظهروا لنا
متجر الإصلاح والتعديل هذا حيث قاموا بإصلاح
معظم المركبات التي تم الاستيلاء عليها من
الروس بما في ذلك ناقل القوات الحديث هذا
حتى مع جميع المعدات الغربية التي
استلمها الأوكرانيون بالفعل ، لا
يزال لديهم الكثير  أقل مما
يفعله الروس ، ولهذا السبب فإن كل دبابة
وكل مركبة مدرعة يمكنهم
العودة إلى ساحة المعركة ستكون حيوية
للجهود الحربية الأوكرانية
التي تشمل حتى المركبات المدمرة على ما يبدو
مثل حاملة الجنود المدرعة المتفجرة ،
يخبرني مدير المشروع بكل هذه المركبات نحن  يمكن استعادة
والعودة إلى الوحدات بشكل
أكبر على طول الخط الأمامي الجنوبي ،
فإن الوضع في المناطق التي غمرتها الفيضانات
مؤخرًا بسبب التدمير الأخير لسد كبير يؤدي إلى
تدهور
أوكرانيا وروسيا التي تتهم بعضهما البعض
باستهداف عمليات لإنقاذ ضحايا الفيضانات.
أمطرت الأمطار لإحضار
الناس إلى هنا من فوق النهر ويقول
الروس
الأوكرانيون إن عدة أشخاص
أصيبوا في هاريسون بينما
تواصل السلطات الكفاح لإحضار أولئك الذين
تقطعت بهم السبل إلى بر الأمان